oh I don't know why did you really go to
lie
what's up guys I'm cute and I love
getting tattoos last time you saw me I
was getting a $2,500 tattoo in Thailand
but this time I wanted to FD a me so I'm
gonna talk to my friend Mary Milan peeny
the witch doctor about getting some
color onto dark skin and getting color
on dark skin is not easy and getting
tattoos with our skin is not easy at all
I've been to several tattoo places
who've not wanted to do cover-ups just
because of dark skin and to have
somebody like Miriam to work with
there's gonna be a blessing so now it's
time to get in a FaceTime call at Miriam
and see about getting color tattoos on
too dark skin
Miriam it is amazing to finally meet you
hi so as you know like I was directed to
come to you because I've heard you the
perfect person to put color on to dark
skin like why are you that go-to person
yes a lot of contrast in my artwork
so therefore a shirt that's amazing so I
tell me about some of the people that
you already tattoo like how did you get
to this level so like can you talk to me
a little more about the tattoo different
Rob stones yeah yeah a little bit show
up really right as of right now I don't
have any inspiration of like anything
colorful that I want to get on my body
[Music]
like wait when al Eamon let's do it
thing tonight yeah I'm done yeah let's
do it okay you know where they're all
one love you know
all right I'll see you there all right
oh my god I don't know why I just agreed
to go to Hawaii
yo they better be pissed I manage money
parents around so I rush home I packed
my bags and try to get to the airport
for this last minute in Hawaii it was
about a five hour trip from Los Angeles
to Hawaii so I had a lot of time in the
air to mentally prepare myself for the
adventure I had had and it was gonna be
a lot going on so the minute I got to
Hawaii
Miriam Jason and the team from tattoo
licious to pick me up from the airport
so we can head to our first stop to find
inspiration for the tattoo the owner
from tattoo licious decided to bring us
out here today it's nobody
like this amazing so we like
inspirational this Beach was the perfect
spot to come to for inspiration the
clear light blue water every Richardson
in the different shades of green we saw
in the turtle were all colors of a pop
on dark skin honestly there could've
been a more ideal starting spot for us
[Music]
copy
some manly tears okay
some manly tears right so after a long
but super inspirational day one we
decided to crash for the night because
we knew that we had a lot of head of us
for day two we decided to check out a
popular hiking trail in awhile where we
find more Green inspiration and
definitely more wildlife
the only issue we had was that we did
zero research before we came to the
trail and that was the first mistake of
many it was at this moment that he knew
he dumb we had these huge water bottles
in our hand and it was stopping us from
going on like the first little hill
so Myriam's like yeah just drop him
horrible mistake for inspiration for
quinces tattoo today and I figured we
gonna see fruits and plants that I never
seen before or drew or tattooed before
but look what we got here so it's the
three of us newbies just walking on this
amazing trail we got Mary I'm here
pointing out the stay on the stream sign
no we took very literally we literally
stayed on the stream the entire time
that was probably our second mistake the
horrible idea let goes horrible so but
it was so fun like we hybrid over trees
climbing under trees it just felt like
we were really out here I felt like I
was under National Geographic so I was
out here feeling real when I nature I'm
like dipping my hand in the water it it
like I'm not tasting come here man got
this dope shot I want you to walk and
I'm a I'm a come from behind a tree
that's gonna be so cool and it was super
cool and everything was going super
smooth until it wasn't
and nearly fell so hard
[Music]
menace let's do what happen okay so the
sign said follow the streets and follow
the stream I slipped on this new human
and broke my nail in the middle any
hurts and now we're trying to figure out
if there actually will be a waterfall
here or if we're just lost hello let's
good to it there mom if you're seeing
this I love you but not quite now we
finally got some reception you trying to
look up for all you need to know before
you go
it says the hike takes around four to
five hours and is on some places
difficult to go but it's a wonderful
journey with great views nice waterfalls
and really good exercise take plenty of
water with you who idea was Italy the
water man congratulations you played
yourself so at this point we're about
two to two and a half hours into this
hike and we've officially made it back
to the original trail it was a great now
sad to see it go so soon the remainder
of the hike was tough but we stuck it
through made some new friends along the
way and finally got through where we
were looking for all right that's all it
up
getting lost we finally made it
[Music]
I've never been so happy to see a piece
of water before in my life but we get it
looks good now we gotta happen here I
was just saying look at it but it was a
hot long walk we got a pen so we did it
we saw so many vibrant colors we knew it
work for the tattoo and we were truly
inspired but unfortunately there was
more bad news to come so even though we
made it to the waterfall we accomplished
our goal we fought through adversity of
getting lost Miriam getting hurt
unfortunately Miriam had to cancel all
the rest of our appointments so the plan
was to just leave Hawaii and head back
to LA and we'll finish the tattoo there
all right so be back in LA I just got to
Miriam spot it's been a couple days
since we've seen each other they
actually stayed at hawai for a little
bit longer than I did let's do it
I'm excited for this tattoo yes so we
just got new floors and I'm about to
start putting murals all over this is
perfect on then let the cook so uh yeah
I'm gonna do this consultation yes come
with me outside here and let's do it you
got a beautiful space thank you it's my
private oasis so Miriam like what do you
think we should do I think we should do
a turtle with a jungle flower Shawn what
you think turtle it was amazing to
finally see Miriam in action for the
last few days I only knew her as a
friend not as his talented tattoo artist
but once we got into the tattoo it was
easy to see why she's so successful why
all these celebrities trust her with
their tattoos it was honestly
astonishing to see the vibrant colors
going into my dark skin and it reminded
me of the amazing ups and downs we had
in Hawaii he reminded me of the people
who said it wasn't possible and most
importantly it reminded me that there's
no limits to the things that you can do
in life especially the things that you
can imagine for yourself and all we
needed was a vision to make it happen
some color for inspiration and a mindset
to look at dark skin as a canvas rather
than an obstacle we experienced so many
cool things again inspiration for this
tattoo and to see it finally all be
executed is such an exciting moment for
me so I just finished her
[Music]
[Music]
so I'm really happy that the tattoo came
out so well and Miriam was able to put
this color on to dark skin but I'm also
really excited about future episodes and
different ways that we're going to be
able to push boundaries with getting
tattoos
[Music]